همم مشاهدينا نعوذ الى
ضيفتنا من كياف نتاليا هومينيوك المتحدثه
باسم قياده العمليات الجنوبيه في الجيش
الاوكراني ولكن للحديث عن ما يجري على
الحدود همم الشماليه من اوكرانيا تحديدا
المناورات المرتقبه بين القوات الجويه
البيلاروسيا والروسيه اضافه الى تفقد قائد
القوات البريه
الروسيه
لقوته في بيلاروسيا هذه
المناورات تثير مخاوف همم كياف على ما
يبدو ونسال ضيفتنا همم نتاليا من كيف عن
سبب هذه
المخاوف اذا لماذا تخشى اوكرانيا تلك
المناورات البيلاروسيه الروسيه مع العلم
انها تستعد اي هجوم روسي من الاراضي
بلا روسيه حتى الان
قال ان اوكرانيا همم تخشى هذه التدريبات
اوكرانيا لم تخشى اي تدريبات من الجانب
البروسي ان اوكرانيا هي دوله تحاول ان
تعيش في عالم متحضر وهي تتعلم هذا بسرعه
اما اا التدريبات في الدوله
المجاوره الدوله
همم ان هذه التدريبات مساله تعود لهم انهم
هم من يحاول ان يخدعوا العالم كله
ويقوم بخدع العالم ويظهر ان هذه التدريبات
هي ليست تحضير للحرب انها تحضر للحرب
وليست تدريبات لذلك لا احد يصدقهم الكل
راى همم حقيقه ان نواياهم انهم يحاولوا ان
يمثلوا انها تدريبات ثم يقوم بتدريب
الجنود ويفرضون على دول الاخرى همم ما
يريدونه هم وهذا لن ينجح معه اوكرانيا في
كل مره كانوا يقولوا للعالم ان هذه
تدريبات سلميه
كانوا يقوموا بعد هذا بتصرفات قذره
ونحن نعلم جيدا هذه القصه وامثله قام بها
القوات البريه
الروسيات بتدريبات ثم
ظهر انهم هجموا على مواقع
اوكرانيه عليهم بدراسه
الجغرافيا جيدا حتى لا يتعدوا حدودنا ولن
نسمح لهم بان يتعدوا على حدودنا بعد هذا
اليوم اوكرانيا تحارب
طيب انقطع الصوت من المصدر
انقطع الصوت من المصدر لا ادري ان كانت
تسمعنا ولكن سيدنا
الان وكانني فهمت منك بانه قد تكون هناك
عمليات حربيه من الجانب
بلا روسيه ضد اوكرانيا وهو الامر الذي
تضعه كيا في اسبانيا كما فهمت انت تقولين
هذه التدريبات حرب وليست مجرد همم تدريبات
وقد يقومون بعمل معين من الحدود
البلاريوسيه
تحدثنا عن انهم
ممكن ان يقوموا بمخادعه العالم كله ونحن
نقول هنا انهم بمجرد النظر عفوا عن
اعمالهم هناك نحن ممكن ان نتوقع اي عمل
عدواني من طرفهم ونحن مستعدين لهذا ونحن
مستعدين لاي تطورات على ارض المعركه او
فاذا قاموا باي هجمات نحن نعلم كيف ندافع
عن حدودنا ونعلم كيف
نصد ايهامات ولن نسمح لهم بعد اليوم ان
يخطئ خطوه على اراضينا سواء كان من اراضي
روسيا او مواقع روسيه
باسمي قياده العمليات الجنوبيه في الجيش
الاوكرانيه شكرا جزيلا لك